[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Hanna
Zimmermann und Christian Sievers nein
einen guten Sonntagabend wie sich die
AFD die Zukunft Europas vorstellt und
die Zukunft Deutschlands in Europa war
lange nicht wirklich klar die einen
wollten den dexit den Austritt
Deutschlands aus der EU andere die
komplette EU abschaffen jetzt gibt es
vom europaparteitag der AFD in Magdeburg
die folgende Linie die EU sei ein
gescheitertes Projekt aber von austritt
und Auflösung ist nicht mehr die Rede
stattdessen soll es einen neu zu
gründenden sogenannten Bund europäischer
Nationen geben der gemeinsame Markt aber
erhalten bleiben you can't have you cake
and eat sagen die Amerikaner eine Partei
zwischen Beschwichtigung und radikalem
Plan oder wie ist der AFD
Spitzenkandidat für die Europawahl
ausdrückt es wird ein Nebeneinander von
disruptiven und evolutionären Prozessen
Nicol Dieckmann berichtet
mit diesen und noch mehr Kandidaten
zieht
die A35 insgesamt 35 Kandidaten für das
EU-Parlament das Parlament der
Institution die die AFD als gescheitert
betrachtet darin ist sie sich einig
welche Forderung sie daraus ziehen will
darüber war ein heftiger Streit erwartet
worden der aber blieb aus aus Sicht der
AFD ist das schon ein Wert an sich wir
haben bis gestern Abend der
Bundesvorstand die beiden Bundessprecher
aktiv auch noch an einen Kompromiss
gearbeitet sodass es heute auch dazu
inhaltlich keine großen Streitereien und
Diskussionen mehr gab
gestern soll es durchaus große
Streitereien gegeben haben aber eben
hinter den Kulissen einen Teil ihres
derzeitigen Höhenflugs zieht die AFD
auch ihre eigenen Einschätzung nach aus
ihrer Geschlossenheit und aus dem Streit
in der Ampel das räumt ihr Parteichef im
ZDF sommerinterview ein
natürlich profitieren wir auch von den
Fehlern der anderen das war immer die
Aufgabe der Opposition Opposition heißt
Kontrolle das ist die Aufgabe der
Opposition das nehmen wir wahr zehn
Jahre nach ihrer Gründung träumt die AFD
von Regierungsbeteiligungen in Bund und
Ländern und wirbt für sich mit ihrem
Kernthema Abschottung zur Bekämpfung des
Fachkräftemangels etwa setzt die in
Teilen rechtsextreme Parteien nicht wie
von vielen Fachleuten empfohlen auf
Zuwanderung sondern auf eher
langfristige Lösungen
ein Kind Politik da müssen wir ansetzen
damit wir in 20 30 Jahren entweder aus
eigener Kraft heraus und das musste
Anspruch einer Industrienation wie
Deutschland mit 84 Millionen Einwohnern
sein aus eigener Kraft heraus mit
unserem Nachwuchs auch wieder die
Fachkräfte generieren können auch in der
Europapolitik fährt die AFD einen sehr
eigenen Kurs statt der ursprünglichen
Forderung nach Auflösung fordert sie nun
nur ungleich weniger radikal einen
Rückbau
das Zielbild für eine Europäische Union
wie wir sie uns vorstellen ist eine
Interessen und Wirtschaftsgemeinschaft
der große Vorteil ist sie haben die
Erhaltung des Binnenmarktes sie haben
freie Verträge Freien güterhandels und
servicedienstleistungsverkehr und sie
haben keine Einmischung mehr in die
Kompetenzen der Nationalstaaten wie das
praktisch umgesetzt werden soll diese
Frage beantwortet die AFD nicht fünf
Tage europawahlversammlung gingen am
Nachmittag zu Ende eine
europawahlversammlung die geprägt war
von sich in ihrer Radikalität
gegenseitig überbietenden Rednern der
völkisch-nationalistische Parteiflügel
hat die AFD fest im Griff
was bedeuten denn die afd-vorstellungen
von einem zukünftigen Europa für uns in
Deutschland wo ja auch andere Parteien
Reformbedarf für die EU sehen aber eben
kein gescheitertes Projekt unser Brüssel
Korrespondent ultra geht die AFD Pläne
an konkreten Beispielen mal durch
peintbild der AFD eine Macht die die
nationalen Regierungen entmündige die
Rechten wollen diese EU weghaben
beschwören Heimat und Vaterland einer
der AFD den Ton angibt formuliert es
radikal diese muss sterben damit das
wahre Europa leben kann da bin ich
überzeugt ja welche Folgen hätte das
Beispiel Europas Wirtschaft ein Leben
ohne die heutige EU in England haben sie
sich den brexit gegönnt versprochen
wurden blühende Landschaften passiert
ist das Gegenteil der brexit ist am Ende
ein verlierer-projekt gewesen das
Wachstum hat sich deutlich abgeschwächt
der Handel mit dem wichtigsten
Handelspartner eben mit der EU ist
massiv eingebrochen auch die deutsche
Konjunktur schwächelt die AFD spricht
von einem Europa der Nationalstaaten
dies wäre eine Gefahr für den jetzigen
Binnenmarkt denn der basiert darauf dass
Nationalstaaten Kompetenzen abgeben ohne
einen des freien Binnenmarkt bekommt die
deutsche Exportwirtschaft
Schwierigkeiten
55 Prozent unserer Exporte gehen in die
anderen
eu-handelspartner und es ist völlig klar
dass wenn es da dann neue
handelbarrieren geben würde dass die
Exporte dann einfach einbrechen würden
Beispiel Europas macht bei der
Nationalhymne kribble es bei ihm sagt
afd-spitzenkandidat für die
europawahlkreis die Verachtung der EU
ein Kerngedanke seiner Partei er fügt
noch einen hinzu den Anti-Amerikanismus
man ist hier in diesem Haus in der
Kommission ihr regelrecht geil darauf
1:1 amerikanische Politik umzusetzen
solche Töne hört der mächtige Mann in
China gerne eine EU die sich von Amerika
abwendet und die in Nationalstaaten zu
zerfallen droht wäre ein Traum für
Präsident schief es wäre ein Leichtes
für den pink die einzelnen nationalen
Staaten auseinander zu dividieren und
das würde unsere hoffentlich zunehmend
Einheit und damit überhaupt
handlungsfähige Positionen gegenüber der
Volksrepublik extrem Schwächen
Beispiel Europas Werte ein Leben ohne
die heutige EU hätte auch Folgen für
Europas migrationskrise das Thema nutzt
die AFD aus verspricht den
Flüchtlingsstrom zu stoppen wir brauchen
die Europa schottet sich bereits mit
Zäunen ab schlägt bereits eine härtere
Gangart an aber ohne eine gemeinsame
eu-asylpolitik wäre das Problem nicht zu
lösen und eine Festung Europa wäre ein
Verrat an europäischen Werten diese
Festung Europa ist ein großer Bluff
außer man ist bereit das gesamte nach
dem Zweiten Weltkrieg aufgebaute
menschenrechtssystem in Europa über Bord
zu werden
die EU muss sterben damit Europa lebt so
die Stimmung in der Partei das AFD
Europa wäre ein ganz anderes
Manfred Weber ist stellvertretender
Parteichef der CSU aber vor allem Chef
der Europäischen Volkspartei im
Europaparlament wo Parteien
zusammengeschlossen sind die sich als
bürgerlich konservativ und
christdemokratisch verstehen und jetzt
bei uns guten Abend herr Weber
kann bald auch die AFD zu ihnen gehören
nachdem was Sie heute gehört haben von
der AFD
die Beschlüsse und die
Kandidatenliste dieser kaum Erklärung an
die Union und an meine Partei die
Europäische Volkspartei in Europa sie
steht gegen all das wofür Vorgänge
Generationen gekämpft haben von Adenauer
Kohl Theo Waigel beim Euro bis hin zu
Angela Merkel die Europäische Union ist
das beste Europa das war jemals hatten
und da kommt von der AFD jetzt seine
Kriegserklärung an dieses Europa und
deswegen werden wir alles tun um die AFD
klein zu halten und wir werden unser
Erbe verteidigen aber jetzt will er die
AFD die EU nicht mehr komplett
abschaffen sondern wie sie heute gesagt
hat entscheidend verändern können Sie
damit eher leben
die europäische unions reformiert werden
das steht ja außer Frage aber wer sich
die Geschichte der AFD anschaut mit dem
Abschaffen des Euros und Ausstieg aus
dem Währungssystem und jetzt auch mit
den Beschlüssen zum Europa der
Vaterländer der weiß dass es einmal ganz
anders Europa geht und man fundamental
anderes Europa geht in dieser
nationalistisch geprägt ist das unsere
Stimme in der Welt da draußen nicht
nicht hören lassen wird deswegen wird
die Grundsatzfrage bei der nächsten
Europawahl zu klären sein ob wir zu
diesem Europa stehen und wer ist cduce
zu stehen also sie wollen ja hier quasi
so eine europäische Brandmauer gegen die
AFD auf wenn man so will gleichzeitig
ist es aber so dass ihre AFD auch
durchaus schon mal mit den
Rechtsextremen zusammen gemeinsam stimmt
im Europaparlament wie passt denn das
zusammen
wir stimmen im Europaparlament so ab wie
es unsere Positionen ausdrücken wie wir
wie wir das für richtig halten und dass
das der AFD in einzelnen Bereichen da
Positionen vertritt ist beim Analyse
leider Gottes der Fall aber klar ist
auch die AFD vertritt in vielen
Bereichen wenn sie sind Europäischen
Parlament mal den Alltag anschauen in
vielen Bereichen radikale Positionen die
nicht die unseren sind für uns als
Europäische Volkspartei wir sind als
Partei Europas diejenigen die vorangehen
wollen und aus meiner Sicht ist das auch
das Wichtigste was wir machen müssen
nämlich erstens
Lösungen in der Sache bei Migration und
auch bei den Ängsten wenn sie um die
Wirtschaftsentwicklung geht das zweite
was man machen müssen ist wir brauchen
ein programmatischen Aufrufe brauchen
Zukunftsperspektive damals im Kampf
gegen die Republikaner in den 90er
Jahren den Euro vorgeschlagen er ist in
die Zukunft gegangen er hat gestaltet
und diese Gestaltungskraft müssen wir
jetzt für die Europawahl auch wieder
aufbringen es ist so ein bisschen
einerseits andererseits was sie jetzt
sagen Herr Weber auch auf italienisch
scheint EU-Kritik für sie nicht ganz so
schlimm zu klingen sie haben sich jetzt
mit der neuen italienischen
Regierungschefin der postfaschistin
melonien ihrer Partei getroffen sich
sogar offen gezeigt für eine
Zusammenarbeit derselben Frau die gesagt
hat ja zur Unabhängigkeit der Völker
Nein zu den Bürokraten in Brüssel das
klingt doch gar nicht so so sehr anders
wie bei der AFD
zunächst nicht verdreht die Europäische
Volkspartei Meloni ist nicht Mitglied
meiner Parteienfamilie und da gibt es
viele Punkte wo ich nicht ihrer Meinung
bin wo wir auch im Designs uns befinden
aber sie haben gesagt
Teil ihrer Parteienfamilie werden könnte
und die Debatte steht nicht an ich
glaube dass die Georgia Melone und auch
die fratella Italia ihre Partei in den
nächsten Wochen und Monaten beweisen
muss dass sie zu diesem Europa steht
aber wer das heutige Regierungshandeln
anschaut und wäre auch sieht wie Georgia
Melone heute auf internationale Ebene
akzeptiert und respektiert ist
mittlerweile der sieht dass sie in die
Mitte gehen will sie hat den Lissabon
Vertrag die heutige Rechtsgrundlage
Europas im italienischen Parlament mit
unterstützt sie hat jetzt in
migrationspakt mit unterstützt im
Gegensatz zu Viktor Orban der das nach
wie vor ablehnt sie will die Gestaltung
Europas noch mal sie ist nicht mit
meiner Partei ich bin nett dazu da ihre
Politik zu erklären aber ich glaube wir
würden einen großen Fehler tun wenn wir
AFD und Churchill melonia auf eine Ebene
stellen weil wir bei AFD klaren
anti-opäismus haben klare Abgrenzung
klar Nationalismus haben und Georgia
Melone jetzt als Regierungschefin in
Italien Europa mitgestaltet sind sehr
weit rechts das geht für Sie die anderen
sind sehr weit rechts das geht für sie
nicht ist das nicht ein schmaler Grat
und eine Argumentation die schwierig zu
erklären ist an die Menschen
die Brandmauer muss klar definiert sein
und für Europa gelten drei Prinzipien
jeder Partner mit dem wir als
Christdemokraten als die Europapartei
zusammenarbeiten muss erstens für die
Ukraine sein das ist in dieser Zeit in
der wir uns befinden selbst erklärend
das zweite jede Partei muss Europa
positiv mitgestalten wollen und sie
nicht abschaffen wollen sowie eigentlich
die AFD das will und das dritte jede
Partei muss den Rechtsstaats akzeptieren
das ist die Brandmauer gegenüber den
piss-vertretern in Polen die
systematisch den Rechtsstaat und die
freien Medien attackieren in diesen drei
Prinzipien gibt es für uns kein Wackeln
wer das akzeptiert kann demokratischer
Partner sein Mitbewerber im politischen
Wettbewerb aber demokratische Partner
und all die anderen die das nicht
einhalten wie die deutsche AFD wie Leben
in Frankreich oder bis in Polen sind für
uns Gegner und werden von uns bekämpft
sagt man zu Weber Chef der Europäischen
Volkspartei im Europaparlament danke für
das Gespräch
ich bedanke mich und wir bleiben noch im
Moment in der Politik aus Berlin heute
Abend eine Nachricht die für die
Linkspartei erhebliche Folgen haben
könnte die Fraktionschefin Amira
Mohammed Ali gilt als Vertraute von
Sarah Wagenknecht die sich ja mit der
Parteiführung überworfen hatte und
überlegt eine eigene Partei zu gründen
Mohammed Ali sagt jetzt sie sei nicht
zufrieden damit wie die Linke mit
Wagenknecht umgeht fragen wir nach in
Berlin bei Karl Hinterleitner guten
Abend Karl jetzt gibt die
Fraktionschefin ihr Amt ab was heißt
denn das für die Linke
ja sieht schon so aus als wir die Linke
langsam beginne sich selbst zu zerlegen
Spannung gibt es ja schon länger jetzt
ist die aufgebrochen als entzündet sich
an der Frage wie umgehen mit Sarah
Wagenknecht die ja mehrmals die Gründung
einer eigenen Partei angedroht hat also
der maximale affron gegen die Partei für
die sich ja im Bundestag sitzt und der
Vorstadt hat daraus die Konsequenz
gezogen sie aufzufordern die Fraktion zu
verlassen und gesagt es gäbe für
Wagenknecht keine Zukunft mehr in der
Linken dagegen wendet sich jetzt die
Fraktionsvorsitzende die wörtlich sagt
dass der Vorstand permanent der Fraktion
seine Linie aufzwinge seinen Kurs
aufzwingen und dieser Kurs beschleunige
die Niedergang der Linken wenn das die
Fraktionsvorsitzende über den Vorstand
sagt dann wird aus der Spannung schon
langsam eine Spaltung und alles kommt
jetzt darauf an wie sich weitere
Fraktion Mitglieder verhalten denn
sollten drei gehen also mehr als zwei
die Fraktion verlassen dann verloren die
Linke ihren Fraktion Status damit
erhebliche finanzielle mittelrechte im
Samstag vernünftige Arbeit in
Ausschüssen wer nicht mehr möglich also
effektive Oppositionsarbeit die geht
dann gar nicht mehr und wenn das
passieren würde dann verlöre die Linke
an Bedeutung und womöglich wäre es das
Anfang vom Ende der Linken als relevante
politische Kraft Karl vielen Dank für
diese Einschätzung Karl Hinterleitner
war das zu der ganz aktuellen
Entwicklung bei der Linkspartei heute
Abend so jetzt der Blick auf die
Weltlage in einer ersten Übersicht mit
Johanna unter schauen wir zunächst auf
die Lage in der Ukraine Russland hat
dort in der Nacht erneut zahlreiche
Ziele angegriffen in kopiens wurde laut
Präsident selenski ein
bluttransfusionszentrum getroffen dabei
soll es Tote und Verletzte gegeben haben
unterdessen war Russland der Ukraine vor
abermals die strategisch wichtige schon
haarbrücke zur völkerrechtswidrig
annektierten Krim angegriffen zu haben
der russische besatzungschef der Region
veröffentlichte Fotos die die
Zerstörungen zeigen sollen zudem
Beschuldigte Russland die Ukraine ische
Armee die Universität in der besetzten
Stadt und jetzt mit Streumunition
beschossen zu haben ein Gebäude sei
dabei in Brand geraten
trotz des auslaufenden Ultimatums der
westafrikanischen Staatengemeinschaft
Eco was lassen die Putschisten in Niger
kein Einlenken erkennen anders als
gefordert ist der entmachtete Präsident
bei Zoom weiterhin nicht im Amt ECOWAS
hatte in diesem Fall mit einer
Militärintervention gedroht von der
Staatengemeinschaft gab es heute bislang
keine Reaktion in der Hauptstadt niamäer
jubelten unterdessen tausende Anhänger
den Putschisten zu einige im Publikum
trugen russische Flaggen
die Union hat von der Bundesregierung
ein Sofortprogramm zur Belebung der
deutschen Wirtschaft gefordert notwendig
sein laut einem fünf-punkte Papier unter
anderem eine Senkung der Stromsteuer und
der Netzentgelte zum Oktober zudem
müssten neue Gesetze die Bürokratie
verursachen gestoppt werden Unterstützer
der Vorschläge sind unter anderem
CDU-Chef märz und CSU-Chef Söder
vor der italienischen Insel Lampedusa
sind zwei Boote mit geflüchteten gekennt
hat eine Frau und ein Kind wurden tot
geborgen mindestens 30 Menschen werden
noch vermisst bei hohen Wellengang
konnte die italienische Küstenwache
insgesamt 57 geflüchtete retten und in
Sicherheit bringen
es ist ein historisches Ereignis aber
keines sein dass man gerne erinnert wird
Slowenien kämpft mit der schwersten
Naturkatastrophe in seiner über
30-jährigen Geschichte zwei Drittel des
Landes sind betroffen schwere Unwetter
Starkregen Erdrutsche drohende
Dammbrüche die Helfer versuchen mit
Hubschraubern eingeschlossene Menschen
zu retten das gesamte Ausmaß ist noch
nicht klar und auch im Süden von
Österreich bangen Sie wolf-christian
Ulrich
hier im Tal der Natur in Norden
Slowenien sind einige Katastrophenopfer
nur mit dem Hubschrauber erreichbar der
kleine Industrieort von einer Sturzflut
fast vollständig zerstört
der Fluss hat alles mitgerissen mehr als
200 Häuser sind hier untergegangen
inzwischen wird das Ausmaß der Schäden
klar
ein manchen Stellen gibt es kein
Flussbett mehr es gibt auch keine Flüsse
mehr es gibt nur noch was Wasser
im ganzen Land Bilder der Verwüstung und
alle packen mit anderen wieder
aufzuräumen die Verzweiflung ist groß
einige haben in wenigen Stunden alles
verloren
bei uns sind fünf Häuser Weg andere
stehen kurz vor dem Zusammenbruch wir
haben hier neun Familien denen wir jetzt
helfen müssen
der Schock sitzt tief ins Slowenien man
geht von Schäden in Milliardenhöhe aus
die Regierung bittet jetzt EU und NATO
um Hilfe die Staatspräsidentin
appelliert in den Zusammenhalt im Land
lasst uns das zusammen ertragen lasst
uns jetzt zusammenstehen die Lage ist so
schlimm dass es nicht über Nacht besser
wird aber am Ende werden wir es
überstehen
auch der Süden Österreichs kämpft mit
den Folgen der Unwetter hier in Kärnten
hat er Dauerregen die Erde so
aufgeweicht dass mehrere hundert
Erdrutsche abgegangen sind und dabei
auch viele Häuser zerstörten hunderte
Menschen mussten deshalb aus
Sicherheitsgründen ihre Häuser verlassen
manche für immer das ist mein Platz hier
bin ich aufgewachsen
das Schlimme ist dass wir jetzt schon
zwei Tage hinter uns hatten mit dem
Hochwasser jetzt das dazu es ist eine
Katastrophe
selbst ein bewaldeten Hängen können die
Bäume das Erdreich nicht zusammenhalten
auch hier Erdrutsche wenigstens nehmen
die Pegelstände in den Flüssen wieder ab
wie hier an der Mur
es gibt eine leichte Entwarnung aber was
von der obersteig Macht kommt kann man
momentan nicht sagen die Anrainer hoffen
jetzt dass die Brücken halten und dass
es nicht wieder schlimmer wird
es ist überall in den Bergen dasselbe
Bild Geröll Erde abrutschende hänge die
Menschen dort berichten wie sie die Welt
um sich herum nicht wiedererkennen
in Slowenien ruft der Geologische Dienst
des Landes die Bevölkerung auf genau auf
Veränderungen am Boden an Gebäuden und
an den Hängen zu achten da tut sich
etwas und es ist nicht nur der Regen und
der durchfeuchtete Boden die Bergwälder
die eigentlich verhindern könnten das
Hänger Abrutschen kämpfen ums Überleben
und wo Wälder und Waldboden zerstört
sind bleibt nichts als Fels wie in
dieser Miebach zeigt
der Wald über dem weichensee in Bayern
Postkarten
doch der scheint trügt unter den
Baumwipfeln spielt sich ein Drama ab
Forstwissenschaftler Axel göttlein
beobachtet wie der Bergwald ums
Überleben kämpft es ist eine
schleichende Entwicklung die durch den
Klimawandel verstärkt verschlimmert
beschleunigt wird es ist an vielen
Stellen eine tickende Zeitbombe wo man
davon ausgehen kann dass der Zünder
schon gezogen ist
ein Teil des Waldes macht Axel göttlein
besonders große Sorgen wo vor 20 Jahren
noch dichte Baumkronen waren jetzt teils
nackte Stämme die Wurzel des Problems
befindet sich an den Wurzeln selbst was
romantisch aussieht ist dramatisch das
ist nicht normal mit den Wurzeln wie die
Wurzeln gewachsen sind vor vielen vielen
Jahren wieder Baum klein war waren die
Wurzeln natürlich im Humus drin Wurzeln
fliegen nicht jetzt sind sie in der Luft
man kann man nachmessen man sieht das
auch unter dem Baum nichts mehr ist der
ist praktisch unten drunter holen und
die Stabilität von dem Baum ist im
Prinzip kaum mehr gegeben die Bäume
verlieren den Boden denn zurzeit gibt es
ideale Bedingungen für das Verschwinden
des Humus steigende Temperaturen und zu
viel Stickstoff in der Luft das ist
genau was Bakterien die den Boden
abbauen brauchen
zurück bleibt nur noch nackter Fans auf
dem rascht alles ins Tal Wasser Lawinen
bei der Bergwald das aufhalten kann
heißt er auch Schutzwald auch im
Oberallgäu wo zwar die humusbilden nicht
verschwinden aber die Bäume
tote Inseln vom Borkenkäfer befallen der
Klimawandel verschlimmert die Bedrohung
wenn wir jetzt aber extreme
hitzeereignisse haben extreme Wärme und
Trockenheit dann kann die Fichte weil
sie schlechter Wasser versorgt ist
weniger Harz produzieren und tut sich
wesentlich schwerer den Käfer
auszuschwärmen und sich abzuschotten
gegen den Borkenkäfer und die Wälder
widerstandsfähiger zu machen gibt es
baumpflanzaktionen hier im Allgäu helfen
Urlauber dabei neue Bäume zu pflanzen
es soll ein Mischwald entstehen unter
anderem mit buchen und Tannen
viele verschiedene Baumarten Pflanzen
Klima stabile das ist im Wald in Zukunft
dann in der für unsere Kinder und den
Enkelkindern dann auch noch gibt und
dass sie dann auch noch nutzen können
wenn alles gut geht steht in 20 Jahren
hier ein neues Stück Bergwald
aber nicht überall kann so ein einfacher
Rettungsplan noch helfen
ja es ist ein Kampf gegen die Zeit und
ein Kampf der sehr teuer ist noch teurer
wird es nur wenn man ihn nicht führt und
das gilt generell bei Naturkatastrophen
Sloweniens Regierungschef schätzt den
Schaden der letzten Tage allein bereits
jetzt auf über 500 Millionen Euro
noch mal du Hannah mit einem
Gottesdienst hat Papst franziskus den
Abschluss des Weltjugendtags der
katholischen Kirche in Lissabon gefeiert
zum Ende des Treffens rief der
86-Jährige die Jugend dazu auf sich in
diesen Zeiten nicht zu fürchten und sich
für den Frieden einzusetzen und 1,5
Millionen Menschen aus aller Welt Namen
an der Messe teil
[Musik]
bei der Fußball-WM der Frauen gab es
heute Jubel bei den Niederländerinnen
sie zogen mit einem 2:0 gegen Südafrika
ins Viertelfinale ein bittere Tränen
dagegen beim Team der USA die
Titelverteidigerinnen sind überraschend
im Achtelfinale ausgeschieden sie
verloren gegen Schweden im
Elfmeterschießen mit vier zu fünf da war
der Ball nur ganz knapp hinter der Linie
erst per Videobeweis konnte der
entscheidende schwedische Treffer
gezählt werden
[Applaus]
die
us-ausnahme-turnerin Simon weil's ist
nach zwei Jahren Pause zurück auf der
Wettkampfbühne bei den US Classics
feierte sie ihr Comeback mit gleich
mehreren Siegen die vierfache
Olympiasiegerin gewann am Boden beim
Sprung und am Schwebebalken und setzte
sich außerdem im meerkampf durch
2021 hat er sich beides wegen mentaler
Probleme zurückgezogen diese standen
auch im Zusammenhang mit dem
Missbrauchskandal rund um ihren
ehemaligen Teamarzt
[Applaus]
und wir bleiben beim Sport auch wenn
sich manche die Augen reiben werden und
Fragen Sport wirklich sitzen die nicht
einfach am Computer und daddeln ich sag
nur 24 Mannschaften
15.000 Besucher pro Tag Preisgeld in
Höhe von einer Million Dollar in Köln
treten sie an um einen der
prestigeträchtigsten Titel in der großen
Welt des eSports bei Europas größtem
counter-strike-event Thomas münden nimmt
uns mit
die Helden einer für viele fremden neuen
digitalen Welt die Spieler Superstars
gefeierte Gladiatoren Frauen gibt es
nicht auf der Bühne aber eine perfekte
Show mit Pyro und Nebel und allem
drumherum dafür sind sie angereist Fans
und aktiv aus ganz Europa von Portugal
bis Finnland
dafür stehen sie schon Stunden vorher in
der Schlange vor den Toren der Kölner
Lanxess Arena um anderen beim
Computerspielen zuzuschauen
ist halt genauso als wenn man
Fußballspiel gucken würde da ist einfach
dieses elektrisierende Gefühl man Fieber
mit seinem Team mit seiner Mannschaft
mit die man anfeuert und ja das machen
mit vielen Menschen halt noch mehr Spaß
ne manchmal wenn du nicht selbst spielen
willst kannst du andere beim Spielen
zuschauen das ist Spaß das ist
unterhaltend
die Stimmung im Stadion und sind so
viele Leute hier na das ist das
Gesamtpaket einfach was es ausmacht
natürlich spielen die Fans auch alle
selbst deshalb drängen sie sich um die
neueste Version die hier vorab zu
spielen ist auf den Bildschirm wird
gemetzelt gebomt gestorben je nachdem
das macht also Spaß
[Applaus]
es hat viel mit Team spielen und
Kommunikation und alles also es ist
nicht einfach so das Spiel selbst kann
man weltweit kostenlos downloaden in
app-käufe und Merchandising lassen die
Kasse klingeln Trikots ab 75 Euro mit
Aufdruck mehr da fließt richtig Geld
ja die kaufen natürlich gern die Team
Trikots ist ein bisschen wie im Sport
man möchte auch sich freuen mit dem Team
mit so einem Team Trikot macht natürlich
gleich dreimal so viel Spaß die Leute
haben hier ihre Profispieler auf der
Bühne die sie anfeuern die richtig viel
Kohle auch mittlerweile verdienen und
die einfach Spaß machen zum Gucken einer
der Spieler ist Karin krimbo muss da
gerade 20 spielt seit sechs Jahren und
verdient sechsstellig damit sein Team
ist schon raus kann man als Spieler alt
werden
und man kann auf jeden Fall bis 30 35
selber professionell spielen und dann
gibt's halt andere Berufe es gibt halt
hier Leute die natürlich die
Kommentatoren oder die Analysten oder da
gibt's so viele Berufe im Hintergrund wo
man natürlich immer erhalten bleibt kann
60 Millionen Menschen weltweit haben das
Spiel auf ihren Rechnern sagen Experten
2011 waren es nur 20 Millionen die
Preisgelder bei den Turnieren haben sich
seitdem verziehenfacht das Gute zum
Schluss nach 2 Minuten pro Stunde sind
zwar alle Avatare tot die Spieler aber
bleiben bis vielleicht auf einen
schmerzendes Handgelenk und verletzt
und jetzt schauen wir traditionell auf
die Woche die vor uns liegt mit Björn
weitner und dem heute journal Ausblick
[Musik]
ab Dienstag steht der Regenwald im Fokus
wenn sich im brasilianischen bellen die
Amazonas Anrainer starten treffen
angesichts von Klimawandel und Raubbau
an der Natur wird die wichtigste Frage
des Gipfels sein wie lassen sich
wirtschaftliche Entwicklungen und der
Schutz des Regenwalds nachhaltig
miteinander vereinbaren
am Mittwoch sind in vielen Ländern
Solidaritätskundgebungen mit der
Freiheitsbewegung in Belarus geplant
dann jetzt sich zum dritten Mal die Wahl
die zu den bislang größten Protesten
gegen das diktatorische Regime von
Präsident Lukaschenko führten der hatte
Gegenkandidaten einsperren und
Wahlergebnisse manipulieren lassen und
Proteste dagegen mit Gewalt
niedergeschlagen
[Musik]
mit einem Festakt wird am Donnerstag an
den Verfassungskonvent vor 75 Jahren
erinnert auf Herrenchiemsee berrieten
Juristen und Politiker über die
Grundlagen für das heutige Grundgesetz
anders zu reflektieren worauf es ankommt
um Freiheit und Demokratie gegen
Extremismus zu verteidigen
und jetzt der Blick auf die
Wetteraussichten morgen überwiegen am
Vormittag noch die Wolken und es gibt
oft Schauer und Gewitter zum Nachmittag
kommt von besten mehr und mehr die Sonne
hervor und die Schauer ziehen sich in
den Osten zurück sieht ein starker
Westwind an den Küsten gibt es Sturm die
Temperatur erreicht 14 bis 21 Grad bis
Mittwoch kann es im Norden noch Schauer
an den Küsten und stürmischen Wind geben
ab Donnerstag scheint überall die Sonne
dazu gibt es 19 bis 30 Grad
also Sommer ab Donnerstag wir zwei sagen
tschüss und ab morgen freuen sich hier
Marietta Slomka und Heinz Wolff Aussee
und die nächsten Nachrichten gibt es
hier gegen 0.30 mit Antoine kuschelken
vom gesamten Team auf den Kolleginnen
und Kollegen hier hinter den Kameras ein
angenehmer Abend tschüss
[Musik]